the most important thing with with
personal branding is consistency over
intensity the more you do something the
more you improve and you try you fail
you learn and you improve you can start
building your personal brand at any time
and the truth is everybody has a
personal brand even if you're not
working on it that's the thing no one
talks about because
simple cells
how are you really good how are you i'm
great dude so
this is this is steven he's got the
coolest instagram name
on the planet just at steven i
immediately went to go look up at
skeeping with a v
um i immediately went to go look up who
had at evan
and it's just some guy who got in early
that was it
so stephen also runs social chain which
is an awesome
marketing agency has a book uh happy
sexy millionaire and if you don't know
his instagram he's got
quotes uh that inspire that push that
that move people forward and so welcome
aboard man great to hear your message
great so great to be with you and you
know i'd love to tell the story about
how i got the um
the instagram name stephen because i get
asked this all the time what what
happened was
um a friend of mine started an app
called unfold well he wasn't a friend of
mine
i'll tell you the story because i think
it it shows there's a lesson in this or
at least there has been for me
um a young a young man won a competition
to come and meet me and he came and met
me in brooklyn in new york
and um he he came and showed me his idea
which was this art portfolio ipad app
um and i told him that it wasn't a great
idea and um and
gave him some tips and advice etc on how
to you know to change it
and um one year one year later a guy
walked into my office in new york and
said
i'm working on three different ideas
this is a completely different guy i'm
working on three different ideas one's
this one's that
and then one's this um app for instagram
stories
and he explained it to me and i said
this is a brilliant idea this guy called
andy i said andy i need to meet the
founder tonight
in brooklyn later that night at 1am he
introduced me to the founder and it was
the kid i'd met a year before he'd
pivoted the app into this app called
unfold
it had a million users at the time and
it was growing like
crazy and i walked into this apartment
in new york this kid is shaking because
it's been a year since he met me and uh
yeah and they just got acquired for by a
squarespace and
i know they've made a lot of money but
so the guy andy as a thank you for
for the help and for the the guidance of
these he actually owned the username
stephen so he gave it to me as a
as a thank you and that's um that's my
story wow
yeah it's crazy how things come back
around so if you the names
how i got this name was because of um i
gave my time to somebody with no
expectations i guess and that's uh
that worked out in the long run yeah i
love it and you're giving back with all
the content you're putting up every day
yeah i enjoy it you know i think i'm
taking as much as i'm giving because
i enjoy it so much i think the process
of creating content and
um producing videos and quotes and
writing is one that's just as self
selfish as it seems um selfless
so yeah i really love it yeah so one of
the things i love doing on this show
since we could do it on instagram live
you can move around
is it either a tour or if there's like
some
some object or something you've got that
has a nice story to it
so it's not just seeing a white
background because is there some object
you got that means something you can
tell us the story
hmm i'm going to pop to my room which is
just that i'll be right back i'll see if
i can grab something give me one okay
okay this is quite this is quite a
symbolic thing for me and it's only a
simple
thing but um a couple of years ago
someone gave me this little piece of
jewelry
and um if you know me if you're close to
me if you're one of
one of my close friends you'll
understand why why this story means a
lot to me
it's just this little lion and um
everywhere in my house in my house i'm
i'm in uh i'm in europe at the moment
but um
in my house in new york and everywhere
where i live and everywhere i go
i have um many many lions everywhere
paintings jewelry
my background of my phone is a lion and
it's one of the things that i think i've
just learned about business over the
years which is
um for me it's been incredibly important
to be able to be
fierce at times sometimes fierce with my
ambitions with my
with my with my team um but also having
that sense of calm and i think
the lion for me has always represented a
real um strong calm and authoritative
leadership
so um the more you know me the more
you'll you know walk around my house and
you'll see that there are
20 or 30 lions there are statues there
are paintings um
and it's a it's almost it's the animal
that i that i resonate with the most for
those reasons
the strength but also the softness and i
think that uh that kind of personifies
me so i could show you this piece of joy
but i have
30 more lines on rings and things like
that that was just the first thing that
came to my mind when i went to my
bedroom
oh yeah that's that's awesome dude now
somebody seemed to like that that uh
they love your youtube channel to change
their life i actually know you were
doing youtube stuff what what are you
doing on your youtube channel
i used to i used to do a daily a daily
vlog so i used to vlog every day there's
two channels you'll see
there's one i have about 55 000 subs my
video it was a daily vlog so video
pretty much every day for about
300 days or so just just business and
running
running the offices and all of the
struggles that
entrepreneurs go through so it was
everything from problems with my
girlfriend
to problems in my personal life to
business challenges and i just shared it
all
um for about for about two years in
total
and i'll be doing it again soon for sure
but uh yeah i ended up moving to new
york which meant that i
am i paused for a second
and so why heavily invest on
because you're in the space and you
teach people about social which is great
i always love the conversation of
why instagram as as the all-in
versus youtube so the way that i look at
it is
um in essence i'm building a funnel with
my audiences and at the start of the
funnel i really have things
um i produce content that can reach a
wide array of people a very broad number
of people
with fairly broad topics so things that
a lot of people can relate to
and as you move down my funnel you have
things that bring you a lot closer to me
um like my podcast which i do pretty
religiously
and then you'll have my youtube vlog and
then at the very end of my funnel you
have
um the the community that are on my own
channels like my sms channel or my
newsletter and those things
and so at the top of my funnel i chose
instagram and
i it used to be facebook as well i have
about 700 about a million people on
facebook but i just
i just didn't really enjoy producing
content on facebook as much as instagram
um and then that's that's really just a
way of getting to know me as i see it
further down
my funnel you really get to know me with
my podcast and my
my youtube vlogs and then at the end of
the funnel we're really connected and
those
that's where i do my webinars and i'll
you know
i'll uh i'll send out my email
newsletter and i think you have to build
that funnel as a personal brand builder
if you want to bring people in the you
know the front door and you know
bring them to the bedroom so yeah
so i flipped it i went linkedin to
facebook to youtube
and and that was where i built we got
two million subs on youtube like that's
for people watching this on the replay
on youtube hey um
and then now more recently on instagram
i want youtube because the content list
forever
because in like five years like this is
a year ago
and people are still saying i love your
videos like wait he's doing videos what
are the videos let me know
yeah yeah yeah yeah no youtube's a
brilliant brilliant channel it's
obviously a lot
more um typically a lot more work
right production work it's you know
longer form you know
over 10 minutes ideally and so as for
someone like me
that um at this point in my life i
i want to produce for a big audience but
i can't necessarily
invest a lot of time into the production
instagram has been a
you know the platform for me but i'll
tell you what linkedin
i've been all in on linkedin for the
last year and a half and um i'm slowly
growing my audience now i've just
surpassed about 100 000 followers but a
mega important platform because of the
virality and how um
you know it's like facebook 2014 where
you know if you comment on something it
spreads it to all of that person's
connections and
that's a an opportunity that won't last
long for sure so
i'm all in on linkedin as well in a big
way have you thought of doing
youtube videos just q a or instead of
like a vlog takes a ton of work to put
together and everything but just
you've got someone you're speaking i've
seen an awesome
um or just being able to answer
questions where you can just sit where
you're sitting
even pull out your phone production
quality the quality is more
like you got you got the quality sure
yeah yeah your opportunities your ideas
are high quality
have you thought of just doing 10 12
minute videos that actually just take 10
12 minutes to
to make and then just post because
you're so good at what you do yeah do
you know what i'm gonna do
is so the way that i look at it as i
never want my things to overlap too much
or else it's a waste of time and what i
mean by that is if i'm sitting down to
record an hour-long podcast every week
anyway
i should just video that yeah and and
that's that's
basically making more out of the same
amount of time so my podcast is called
the diary of a ceo and it's doing really
really well it's
huge over here in the uk and some
business charts it's either number one
or
um in the top ten and um i'm gonna start
videoing that the issue i've always had
with this
videoing it honestly just speaking
honestly is um i'm
most of them so i live in new york
that's my only you know
that's really my only official residence
and i've been there one week this year
and that speaks to my schedule so i'm
typically flying about four days a week
and if you think about scheduling
podcasts anywhere i really don't know
where i'm gonna be we have
five offices around the world we have
700 team members and my job is to fly
between the offices but also to do a lot
of public speaking and
you know you know those kinds of things
so i'm i've just that's been the big
issue for me is how do i record a
podcast
um and a lot of these are excuses as
well because i know
i know that there's ways around it it's
just like i think the most important
thing when you come to building a
personal brand or producing content
is you need to find something that you
enjoy and that is sustainable
and if you can do something that you
enjoy in a sustainable you'll become
consistent and the key to personal
branding is consistency
so i don't try and trick myself into
doing anything that i that i don't find
sustainable or enjoyable
and um and i think i i just i had a
conversation with my team recently where
i said i want to start
um doing more youtube but uh i think
it'll be
videoing my podcast yeah unless he needs
to start
um yeah i think also for a lot of people
it's just
being willing to lower the production
quality like maybe it's you're feeling
off your phone while you're in the back
seat of an uber
or cab going an airplane with a thought
that's on you because you see that
you're such a unique dude you see the
world
differently like you step out as streets
in new york
and everybody else sees one thing and
like you're seeing this you're noticing
that guy
there on the corner doing it right and
so just
what's going on in your head is value
forget about
like the perfect lighting or the setup
or you know the stuff
um if you are like and i know you run a
marketing agency so like
there's a little bit of care about it
but i think um
just like you i love what you do in ig
where you've got your personal
right stephen which is not talking about
marketing
it's it's personal development it's
growth it's you know ambition and
motivation and just inspiration
it's great and then it's just in your
bio oh i'm also the ceo of social change
you can go there and see
all the all the marketing here too um
yeah i mean i would i would i would love
to see the podcast is a super easy one
i'd love to see just your thoughts
though like
how you see the world yeah that's it
that's it that's exactly what i do on my
podcast so my podcast is
most of the time is alone and in fact
the episodes that do the best are when i
am alone
and it's one hour of me showing you
what's in my diary based on the last
week
so it could be you know some massive
issue with my mom it could be a massive
issue in business it could be an issue
with a team member it could be
someone that sits down next to me on the
plane and something i learned by how
they behaved
you know and it's and it's that real
sort of like um observational
um analysis that i just pour out
completely honestly in a way that that
um hopefully won't get me cancelled so
uh but it really is raw it's you know
it's raw i talk about everything i've
talked about masturbation
and whatever else but i just need and
that of all of the pieces of content i
produce is the one that has the greatest
sort of affinity or
the greatest connection with my audience
but it's not recorded
by far by far and this is also why i
stopped facebook so
i made five facebook videos on facebook
watch when it came out and they averaged
10 million views so it made a lot of
money
but i but it was a three second a three
minute video
um about sort of vague um
broad appeal topics and i just didn't
get a lot out of it to be honest i was
trying to make viral videos
and i wasn't getting a huge amount out
of it so my podcast was almost like
therapy for me it was a
it was like yeah cathartic experience so
yeah well long form definitely works on
youtube and
oh for sure dude if you can nobody can
carry
a one-hour solo podcast
mm-hmm like you know that's my favorite
thing yeah it's my favorite thing
because you just you got a perspective
that is just different that's right i'll
do it i'm telling you
that i'm gonna do it i'm gonna do it i
have to make i have to find a way to
make it like truly sustainable and
and i've always you know fantasized
about having a big studio that i could
record it in
and in manchester we have eight studios
we have a studio in new york but i'm
never in either
and so what happens in my podcast is
it's recorded i swear to god i'd say
80 of the time in a cupboard under some
stairs somewhere
where i can just have in a hotel where i
can have
um silence and and and that's it and you
know i can't really record in that
cupboard
in the hotel so it's uh it's been a
tricky one i think um
dude i would love to see i would love to
see the guy who's got offices all over
the world
beautiful new york apartment and then
here he is like sitting under a
a staircase in the cupboard whatever
filming yeah
that's what everybody else is trying to
be perfect and have the perfect studio
you're the guy who says just go just
make just love yourself don't don't
worry about the judgment right now like
here you are living it
i think that would be fire dude i'm
gonna maybe i'll do that under the
staircase
that could be the name of the podcast
under the staircase
good idea yeah man i wanna well i mean i
i match up a whole bunch of different
people's things and try to introduce new
thought leaders
so part of this is selfish to me like
i'd love to showcase your stuff and say
hey
you may know stephen from instagram and
podcast and his books and
speaking gigs but like check out his
youtube you got to dive into this guy
um cool that's just george i just
yeah justice for george too that's
everyone's saying in the comment section
wild so so talk within that
talk about how do you manage you've got
your personal brand
that's not super connected to social
chain i mean it is but the content isn't
you got social change you got topics
like justice for georgia that are super
timely
for entrepreneurs who are looking at you
and they say hey i want to i want to
have my personal brand and my business
brand and
topical like what how do you manage it
all what advice do you give somebody who
wants to emulate what you're doing
yeah so i think it's really i think
there's a couple of things here that are
really important
i think um you can start building your
personal brand at any time and the truth
is everybody has a personal brand even
if you're not working on it right you're
if you have an instagram profile or a
linkedin or you have any online presence
or even if you don't
you've got to view it through the
perspective that everyone is a brand and
has a personal brand
what you write in your twitter bio what
you post about this all
um you know comes together to build what
your personal brand is
and um i i here's my advice to people
building a personal book
i would focus initially especially if
you don't have the budget to hire a team
i would focus on one hero channel
that channel is usually determined by
the content that you're going to be
producing so if you're a chef
there's fairly obvious channels for you
to go down you're not going to start
necessarily you probably wouldn't go for
a snapchat
right you'd probably go for either like
an instagram or a video first platform
like a youtube or an instagram
um you wouldn't go for a twitter for
example if you're a chef necessarily
and i try and build an audience on that
hero channel
the most important thing with with
personal branding is consistency over
intensity which means
as i said at the start really finding
one thing that you can
um do consistently for the next five to
ten years
if you look at the growth of you know a
lot of people that i thought
astronomical personal brands
across the board they were really they
typically were really consistent
on one hero channel and then they used
that audience to then branch out you've
got jay shetty
he started in 2016 with videos on
facebook you've got garyvee over here
with wine libra you know with wine
library and
what he did on youtube as the wine guy
back in 2000 in what bloody you must
have in 2009 or something 2008
um and you've got um you know i've got
i've got friends that have built
newsletters that have 500
000 subscribers and then now they've
branched out onto other channels like
medium
and i would really focus in on just
being really consistent
and providing incrementally more value
every
every quarter month whatever you want to
do on that channel
over time that for me and the other
example i give is casey nice
nice that who you know took him i think
he said it took him six years to get was
it six hundred thousand subs or
something and then
the next year he got to six million or
something crazy like that through his
daily vlogging and again like it's so
apparently clear
that what matters more than anything
else as is the case with wealth and
compounding interest
is consistency and in fact the the
the fact that um most important is the
amount of time you put in to
put into the craft some people will say
you know as a rebuttal to that
no steve what matters the most is the
quality of the content but the truth is
the more you do something the more you
improve and you try you fail you learn
and you improve and as you know you look
at anyone that's
exceptionally good at anything lebron
james he didn't start good at basketball
he's
he's a world champion he's the mvp
because of his consistency
and i think that's what we should be
aiming for everybody wants it overnight
which is
understandable i would like it overnight
too but as it relates to personal
branding the fastest way
happens to be the slow way and in fact
the only way
and i think that's what you know when
people you know get asked this question
all the time how do you build an
audience how do you build a personal
brand
it is it is an incessant focus on
consistency and if you can get your 100
followers
to tell a friend you know if they're all
telling um
or if they're spreading your content to
10 of people and five percent of those
are deciding to follow you
then it will only take you you know as
in a compounding way if you look at how
compounding interest works
it'll only take you a couple of years to
to have a much bigger audience and if
you wait two more years you'll have a
exponentially bigger audience and two
more years after that it'll get even
bigger and that is the
that is the secret nobody talks about
everybody wants three tips and tricks
and secrets but uh
maybe it's just consistency maybe that
holds the answer to both you getting
better at your craft but also
um exposing more people to your craft by
growing your audience
the first five years of my youtube
channel i had 7 000 subscribers
there you go yeah and the next five it
was up to two point whatever million
and there you go right and in those
first five years
you in fact did all the work to get to
for the next five years it's how i look
at like
like personal wealth like you know
because i've said this to a number of my
team members over the years right i've
said um
say that i say that i'm worth let's just
use a random figure plucked out here say
that i'm i've got a hundred million net
worth now
um my first four years after you know
when i dropped out of university at 18
years old
i like messed around with a startup i
learned tons of stuff but i ultimately
like it failed right
it ended when i started my next company
i came into it with all of that
information all of that knowledge
i knew investment i'd raised investment
13 times in my first startup
i had all this information so my next
company social channel it's a publicly
used company now
it's worth 100 200 million on the stock
exchange still undervalued
revenues this year are going to be about
220 million dollars alone
and when i think about when that wealth
was generated i tell everybody it was in
those four years
so i don't say okay in four in the four
years of social channel we we generated
200 million
i stretch it across the last eight
including my failed startup
and say in fact when you look at it
we've really made you know you know 40
million a year since i was 18.
but you you get to take it to the bank
you know further down the line and
there's a lot longer you leave it you
know the more
it compounds it's the same with your
youtube channel the first five years
when no one was really listening
were the years when you were learning
about the algorithm and thumbnails and
titles and had comments and the like
button and all these things and so
you come into that next five years and
[ __ ] just goes like this right
because the content's better you know
all of these things that's the thing no
one talks about because
simple sells and if evan says it's gonna
take you ten years
and you're gonna get the payoff in the
last five everyone's gonna get this guy
and they're gonna walk off
yes and they'll go in search of simple
you know and that's
um it's you know no one wants hard work
and patience
no one my first video
in one year for being up had three
comments the first was my mom the second
was my older sister and the third was
some random guy
in one year of the video being up three
comments wow
crazy and now you're a juggernaut on
youtube i see your videos everywhere
i'll be laying in bed and i'll hear your
voice and it's just because it's like
rolled over to the like the next video
well it's two we're gonna be featuring
some steven on the channel
oh here we go under the staircase
i've watched so many of your videos you
wouldn't believe hundreds probably you
know amazing
amazing what you've done really amazing
well listen it's crazy how how time
flies when you're having fun
for people who are um in my audience
and youtube who are maybe discovering
you for the first time
where like how do they dive into your
world where do you want them to go next
the best place to get to know me would
be my podcast which is
the diary of the ceo and you know
start anywhere you like whatever episode
resonates with you start
at the start if you want to see how it
improved over time and at the start i
give a bit of context into my story but
yeah the diary of a ceo definitely and
i'd love to have you on sometime evan
it's uh it's got a big uh millions of
people listen to over here in europe so
i think your story would be a
spectacular i'm down let's do it
appreciate it stephen thank you man
thank you thank you very much thank you
appreciate you
much love if you want to see the one on
one i did with bishop td
jakes check out the video right there
next to me i think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there